a report commissioned by the uk
government and adopted by the united
nations estimates that 10 million deaths
may occur
each year by 2050 due to antimicrobial
resistance if nothing is done
but something is being done the food and
agriculture organization
fao together with the government of
kenya have designed interventions to
fight antimicrobial resistance in
poultry production in kenya we have
deployed interventions that are related
to proper feeding
vaccinations and improving hygiene
antimicrobial resistance shorthand as
amr
is a global public health threat in
simple terms
antimicrobial resistance refers to
as the situation where the germs are not
killed by the drugs that used to kill
them before
the process of antimicrobial resistance
though occurring naturally
is escalated by misuse and overuse of
antibiotics
to address this interventions need to be
instituted in both human and animal
[Music]
health
gatundu north has one of the highest
concertation of farmers involved in
rearing of commercial layers
in a knowledge attitude and practices
study done in this area
fao found out that out of the 10 most
common diseases
in poultry four can be prevented through
vaccination and six can be prevented
through hygiene
fao then conducted a pilot project that
involved training of about 50 poultry
farmers in best practices in poultry
production
the project adopted the farmer field
school approach where the farmers were
divided into three groups
learning took place in a class without
walls and a fully stocked poultry unit
was also availed for practical lessons
we are trying to train our farmers
to clear their chicken produce
eggs that are free from
antibiotics cow
it is possible and profitable
to rear chicken without the use of drugs
because antimicrobial resistance is
brought about by misuse and overuse of
drugs
and drugs are mostly needed to cure
diseases therefore if diseases are
prevented there would be no need for
drugs
and hence reduced occurrence of
antimicrobial resistance
since most diseases are brought by about
unhygienic conditions
improvement of hygiene and biosecurity
was the main focus of training in the
farmer field schools
already the farmers have begun
implementing the lessons learned in
their poultry farms the farmers
have actually changed they are already
practicing what
we've been able to to teach them how to
train them
and at the moment the three groups are
already able to produce
eggs which are free from antimicrobial
residues
[Music]
my name is steven gacho himboro when
you observe proper hygiene you hardly
make use of
any drug and we have realized that is
true
[Music]
i don't remember when the last time that
i used drugs
i passed right since the fire came in
actually
when checking my record i wondered what
happened to the diseases that
used to inflict my birds
stephen is planning to reconstruct his
poultry unit to conform to what he has
learned in farmer's field
school nancy on the other hand has
improved her bio-security measures
this is the 26th week of training and
the birds in the poultry show house have
attained
peak production with no death from
disease
we are hoping that this this knowledge
the farmers have received it will be
cascaded
outwards in fact it can be done
internationally the farmers are proud
and happy as they are graduating in a
ceremony presided over by fao and
government representatives
i'm not just like any other farmer i
have graduated i'm very happy about that
i have a certificate that can actually
present it
somewhere in an office yeah and that
means that i've been given a go ahead
to do as much as i would like about
those birds i have a lot of knowledge
[Music]
you